wer am anfang geglaubt hatte das amt
werde donald trump mäßigen lag falsch
der ex bauunternehmer hat die säulen der
amerikanischen demokratie untergraben
das volk hatte ihn ins weiße haus
gewählt er sah das als umfassende
vollmacht andere zentren der macht
sollten spuren einzug in den kongress
durch die reihen seiner mittlerweile
ergebenen partei er hat sich die
republikaner gefügig gemacht gegner
gefeuert per twitter gegen jeden gehetzt
der sich ihm in den weg stellte und
spätestens beim impeachment hat sich das
ausgezahlt ergebnis
[Applaus]
david from arbeitete für george double
you busch erfand für ihn den begriff
achse des bösen
und dann stellte sich der konservative
gegen den präsidenten aus der eigenen
partei wo das parlament die macht nicht
mehr einschränkt wird freie presse zur
letzten rettung kam erklärte ihr täglich
neu den krieg hemmungslos hetzte er
seine anhänger gegen die feinde des
volkes transporter zündeten
er redet so sack from weil er demokratie
verachte er verstehe sie nicht
die verfassung der usa bricht die macht
des präsidenten in 50 bundesstaaten
denen er nichts vorschreiben kann auch
diese stütze des rechtsstaats hat trump
untergraben
gestützt auf kriegsrecht aus dem
neunzehnten jahrhundert schickt der
bundes ruppen in demokratisch regierte
staaten damit sie dort auf chips weise
aufräumen auch in washington brachte er
bundespolizei gegen demonstranten in
stellung damit der law and order
präsident vor einer kirche die er nicht
besucht ein buch hochhalten kann nachdem
er nicht handelt der gefährlichste
angriff auf die säulen der demokratie
war die untergrabung des wahlrechts im
chor o na ja wenn sieg und niederlage
von briefwählern abhängen würden
ressourcen der post verschrottet trump
glaubt dass hohe wahlbeteiligung für ihn
ungünstig sei wie in dunkelsten zeiten
wird wieder unterschieden zwischen
erwünschten und unerwünschten wählern
und stimmabgabe zur zumutung gemacht wo
falsche mehrheiten drohten die rechnung
ist nicht aufgegangen
es gab eine enorme mobilisierung
überwiegend gegen
nun zögert der präsident und zögert und
zögert die wahl anzuerkennen
der bauunternehmer sind auf neue pläne
auch diese säule noch zu untergraben und
in seiner festung zu bleiben